can really relate to bees in the tropics
love summer
I had these in my back bedroom which was
kind of a trap I needed to be chopped
because there is a lot of discussion on
the internet about what beez in the trap
means can you be definitive Nicki Minaj
what should I say um let me think so
bees is the letter B B for boys or is it
bees as in buzzy bees is it no no it
just means that you know it's the saying
I am always you know that's our slang
way of saying you know we'd like a bees
and when such and such and such oh
really it's like I am always in the trap
now the trap ladies and gentlemen
relates to anywhere that you get your
money the trap right now playboy oh yeah
[Applause]
playboy I'm very down with this because
I mean I've been reading my dictionary
[Music]
yeah hang on will let's find my
dictionary it's on here so it's all you
on here so like strawberry shortcake yes
I hid that word strawberry shortcake
now definition a broad [ __ ]
when you lose a sight of her goals and
our cake by focusing on beef and
negativity yeah you strawberry shortcake
[Laughter]
you better penthouse your ideas a little
test for you test me test me okay who is
Balloon Boy Oh balloon boy is this a
sexual thing isn't it no okay it's a
balloon boy is a Ken with no stacks no
balloon boy I remember back in America I
don't know if you guys heard when that
little but you know the boy that he was
in a balloon and I did a rap and I said
you like balloon boy mama
[Applause]
because I'm passionate about children
and I just want to eat them up and kiss
them when I see them and when I saw up a
lone boy he looked so precious I said
you know what I'm gonna make him the
honorary Oracle of Barb nation and he's
and he became like you know I don't know
some like godly force in the barb nation
[Applause]
whew Strawberry Shortcake's over there
it's
yeah they better tumble dry yeah
we've got the definition tumble dry word
tumble dry verb definition used when
speaking to washed-up [ __ ] [ __ ]
tumble dry
when when you leave here tonight and
you're in the car going home will you
describe me as a Waffle House sure
because a Waffle House is word Waffle
House adjective definition a clearly
misguided old wrinkled
[Applause]
[Music]
you